[Music]
ding-ding-ding-ding welcome to the
podcast highly requested I don't know
why you guys like watching car cast
brush amazing whole food ingredients
packaged up individually for your dog
time delivered to your house and
shipments
to where you don't have to go and feed
your dog some kibble that's what
government wants right now if your dog
cries like that feed it farmers dog and
then they won't cry anymore all right
now guys get 50% off your first two week
trial by going to the farmers dog.com
slash generate Julian the link is also
below also guys Squarespace the best way
to build a website is with Squarespace
they have amazing different array of
templates
they have 24/7 award-winning customer
support it's building a website made
easy how are we gonna do this with him
screaming we thought it would be like a
nice thing to bring the whole family
along and do a car cast together but
Kermit has nothing plans right now oh my
god but I have to hold him for him to
stop screaming okay well what we can do
is you can trick him so if we're like
he's upset because he doesn't know where
we're going and he like wants to be
there already so we can go like stop by
a park like an open field let him run
around for a second and then bring him
back in the car and then he's like happy
you know cuz he thinks that he went to
the thing we were going to but because
he's
so if we give him a fake destination
yeah or I can hold my arm like this and
touch him the entire time which also
works it just hurts my shoulder after
any amount of time that joke the ITO
that you that you're his therapy person
that's not a joke therapy person I'm not
his mom I'm not his friend or caretaker
of his therapy person well anyway this
is the first car cast I think is the
only one we've done this year I don't
think there's been a 2018 card and also
it's the first car cast we've done in my
Jeep Molly I love the Jeep welcome Dean
Pham to the Jeep my Grand Cherokee that
I bought this year I'm so in love with
it it's so it's like really a fun great
car I I got the drive in the in the
pouring rain with it the other day and
it was so satisfied
something about being in the car that's
much bigger than my old car like the
Civic was tiny it was a coupe it only
had two doors I have this I have a
sunroof so and it's like dual so I can
see all the rain coming down right I
don't know like being in a big old Jeep
when it's when there's weather it's not
a lot of weather here safety features we
had a lot of rain last week it was
pretty good yeah I have safety features
I have freaking I have sensors sensors
and I have auto braking and cruise
control adaptive cruise control dude
come on in the dream here then I've
already said to Julian that the next car
that I buy I want it to be able to drive
itself like not a Tesla I'm hoping that
the market becomes competitive enough
for self-driving electric cars by you
know 2020 or after a little bit 2025 I
don't know because my car is in totally
fine condition it's it's like this it's
an SUV except it's a 7 passenger so you
can fold down a nice little back row
seat and fit all the old friends in it
but I said to Julian that the next car
that I buy I want it to be like alright
this is your car this is Julien's like
beep beep mobile and mine will be the
alright everybody hop in and shut the
hell up and I'm also not driving it
Tesla's like they have Auto drive
features but they're not like a
primarily auto drive a car like people
buy a Tesla
boy like it's just a feature of the test
that's not how that has the works
primarily yeah I mean it's also a Tesla
it's electric it's yeah you know there's
a lot of reasons why people love Tesla's
I would love it it doesn't need to be
super premium but I would love it to be
electric
that would be super rad but I'm hoping
that the by the time I'm in the market
to buy another vehicle because mine is
it's a 2013 so by 2023 it'll be 10 years
old maybe time to consider getting
another car then it would be time to see
if there's something that I don't have
to drive really yeah I mean you have to
sit think you know how driving
self-driving cars work you know be able
to sit there and drive it but you can
throw that [ __ ] in some autopilot you
know what I'm saying
sure do you think for the market to get
competitive enough so where there's not
just one choice but multiple and also to
where I am yeah I have no idea I don't
know anything about cars really but I
have read that obviously other car
companies are trying to get in on the
self-driving technology or market or
whatever so that by you know 2025 I'm
hoping I'll have a competitive choice
that's not a Tesla you know I pitched
what is it you're so beautiful you're
the only one that's so good in the car
and doesn't scream you cry because she's
an angel Marbles pretty good in the car
he's just sitting with me because I
really I just need him today you ever
like have a day when you just like
really need your dog yes really need my
dog today yes carmit can totally do
without screaming today like if you were
just like a little less screaming today
every day ever
is about him why what's going on with
any of us hi peach every day is about
karma and so when you're having a rough
day and you need your dog you have peach
and marbles yeah
permit mixing about him no matter what's
going on Oh which I'll get in but yeah I
think it would be really great that by
the time I buy my next vehicle
I don't I don't always have to drive it
I think that'd be super fun it would be
cool imagine like that would change
everything just he's strapped he can
stand there it's just it's to get closer
to you and cried this phone nasty I
think my Jeep will I think
at least ten years the only thing we
want bigger chief tires why are we gonna
go off-roading yeah where are we gonna
go
where can you off row down a mountain
but it's not because I want to go off
the mountain just like a cartoon you see
like the road too big there's like a
winding road didn't you just see Chile
going it and destroyed like I love being
higher up in the Jeep and you can
actually why this boy gonna have
gigantic tire driving up the side of a
mountain
oh ma well then what are you gonna drive
like to go to the grocery store what how
are you gonna carry your groceries I've
got a grocery shopping on my last report
and oh yeah well usually four car casts
we go to a place called donut friend and
get donuts because it's usually a Sunday
night and it's usually when we're gonna
have cheat meal and have some donuts but
we're just gonna get lost tonight yeah
we're kind of like not feeling daughter
friends just because like Amy we have
the dogs but don't a friend every night
we go there no matter what time or what
day the way it's pop in there it is
poppin it's hard to find a parking spot
I mean I'm like in the mood right now
to not interact with anybody if I can
help it umami all the time
I just I'm like I'm ready to not do that
right now
today's Sunday we we had some drinks
last night gamed a little bit we haven't
had like cheat meal though like cheap
dinner what do you want for dinner
Kermit do you want pate maybe about a
see the dogs Kermie there's so many
doggies out tonight I'm surprised
there's nothing we've seen like 11 dogs
walking around and he hasn't barked at
any of them we're also recording this on
a different camera and lens than all of
our other car casts what do we record
the other ones on the a7 s and also we
have a wider slower lens but I figured
the wide the wider so here we come
comedians in cars getting coffee getting
cars comedians and coffee getting cars
and cars going to buy other cars
that's just Jay Leno because in cars
getting cars thank God
comedians in cars getting in arguments
[Laughter]
he
it's so funny we were at like a social
event yesterday and you know like I was
meeting people we were being adult and I
noticed that when people with like a
spec house a house or like you know
what's going on with us I like lead with
oh we're getting curtains and I'm like
so proud of it it's like such a weird
thing you know we're finally getting
curtains you know like the only thing
more adult
I think getting curtains yourself is
bragging to other people about how
that's what you're excited about
yeah we're those people that's my that's
my that's where I'm at right now in life
we go to Home Depot tomorrow maybe Bed
Bath and Beyond I don't know full of
time what are you doing I don't know how
to help you bud you should seriously
just like let him out for a minute
somewhere and then put them back in the
car answers oh you gonna meow at us
Wow permit how about this okay we'll
find a place I don't know where but we
can find a place where we can let you
out
it's actually like pretty mellow crying
right now usually it's like a screen
like a full screen it's a real heavy
breathing bud
yesterday
jenna was playing yeah and like and I
like music and I just started dying
laughing because you were dancing this
is the BPM of my Pinot Grigio how you
gonna blow up my spot like that so well
like Jillian said we were at a party
yesterday we're at Meg's engagement
party meg like works with us on our
financials on our businesses we love her
so much and she got engaged so she had
an engagement party so we went to her
engagement party I had one glass Pinot
Grigio but I like hadn't really eaten
anything all day so I was like kind of
turned off this one glass of Pinot
Grigio so we get in the car and it's
like you know daytime sunny out like I
had a Pinot Grigio in the middle of the
day you know what I mean
and I was feeling live sois through once
and bops
and I said that was the BPM of my people
Grigio because I was like Danny but then
I was playing all songs that were all
that BPM that was the BPM of my Pinot
Grigio sorry sorry y'all just beating it
32 you a lady
peachie you're such a good girl now she
can have this spot she likes this spot
it is so festive it's Hanukkah over it
is right Oh Happy Hanukkah we've lit the
candles maybe three of the Nights I'm
really sorry
that's okay we have the menorah do your
best
more feet where Oh oh my god literally
on the front of it
hi sisters that's crazy there's like
nothing else on display it's just just
him that's enough to get anybody in the
store a beach he is I also think it's
really rad how he's so young and doesn't
like openly says he's sober and like
doesn't drink or like smoke weed or do
anything that a lot of teenagers can't
wait to do you know what I mean I think
it's really rad he's a smart kid he how
are you making it cool good
he's quiet at times yeah cuz if you hold
him then he's fine okay that bar
literally has western doors that open
into it did you see that no what the
hell
Jimmer yeah how can they do that that
must feel like a fake front door it's
probably entered into a door yeah did
you remember the last time we did a car
cast and someone we watched two people
on horses we're ID into town drunk
people drunk people on horses no that
was after the car cast I think I
remember like pulling out my phone and
filming her no maybe it was I did I
pulled out my phone and filmed it who's
so funny
this is my favorite thing to do yeah
just like get in your car at night and
just go on a little adventure
it's like what I always used to do just
look get in the car oh that sounds fun
Wow don't threaten me with a good time
pinball and pizza ever go to like
chuck-e-cheeses or Shakey's
what's Shakey's well it's Shakey's I'm
pretty sure Shakey's in Santa Monica if
it's still even there is like a pseudo
chuck-e-cheeses I don't think it's still
there I don't know it I've never but
it's like yeah it's like a kids arcade
slash pizza place different parties
Shakey's I can't even pinpoint it oh
that's a still seat belt
joki Jews really isn't that great there
is a place like where I grew up I think
it was called like Discovery Zone or
something and it was just like this huge
you know all the cargo nets and like
ball pits and like it was a lot more
active you know what I mean
yeah like the emphasis was like
trampolines and jumping and running
around
whereas chunky cheese is like I went
there as an adult and it's like a couple
of sad little [ __ ] machines like
games and then a weird animatronic show
with some weak Pizza yeah I was never
like I was a kid I didn't go to those
types of places a lot just cuz like I
don't know I think most of the Pope
likes parties birthday parties into
where kids houses yeah yeah I didn't go
to a birthday party at Chucky Cheese
either also my mom just didn't want us
eating with that food so I never got to
you although I really wanted to one time
my birthday landed on Yom Kippur which
like so much of my school was Jewish so
we like you know if they didn't give off
for high holidays like half more than
how the schoolers wouldn't show up so
that we've gotten them off yeah so Yom
Kippur fellow my birthday and I got the
whole day off for my birthday that was
so magical and went mini-golfing yeah my
brother always made it about him but
really always made my birthday about him
he was the crown he was the Kermit he
would find some way to like have more
fun at mini-golf than me and like finish
all the holes before me and then like
brag how well he did and like make it
about him
I don't know he's so annoying
by the way I guess my niece learned at
her preschool how to do the philosophy
is like the backpack kid I saw that text
and he Utah she taught my brother how to
do it I'm dying to learn it from her and
I'm dying to watch my brother do it I
don't think I peach all right you know
what we're going pretty slow and
everybody's up front
except for Miss peachy come on baby wait
why what's the matter why why you
stressed
I'm telling you if you if you let them
out of the car somewhere they'll think
that like that was such a cool fun place
that you just took them put them back in
and they'll be happy to sit there no
what do you think miss wheet I can hear
that from here it's like whistles well
on its way out
just cover it breathing like it's gonna
oversee to us talking car sounds I
didn't know where we are
we're in Burbank Oh fine alle fornia
home of a lot of film things like what a
lot of film studios Oh like the one over
the lot oh and then you have there's a
lot of like gear rental places
production companies all that sort of
just like film city water like
everyone's like thinks that Hollywood
houses this kind of thing Hollywood is
just the flashy bits a lot of things are
filmed out here like the first time I
realized that like all of the office was
filmed in the valley I was like losing
it because then everywhere I would go I
would be like oh my god how I thought
they were in Pennsylvania immerses you
feel immersed I was immersed and then
they draw and then they're over there
driving like on the one I want I'm like
this isn't going to New York no it's not
yeah a lot of stuff is filmed I hear
it's pretty well actually I've said it
many times but JJ's diner from
I like parts Parks and Rec you do like
Parks America not as much as I like
Seinfeld though Julian loves Seinfeld
you and watching Seinfeld he loves it he
laughs he shot off the office the other
day to put on Seinfeld cuz you've never
seen it before and it's funny right you
beat you liked it who's your favorite
character George is so freakin funny
Elaine - Elaine's pretty great
like just watching George go through all
of the [ __ ] that his character thank you
Wow I feel so validated like when he
gets mad because he keeps
self-sabotaging in every way possible
yeah oh my god that is so funny mm-hmm
I know we could do what this trip we
could go to the Whole Foods oh I love
Whole Foods it's the only Whole Foods
that you go to and you're like wow that
was a lovely experience right you need a
second there's a Walmart here since the
[ __ ] Winn I did not know there was a
Walmart here fun
I haven't been to a walmart since like
forever I didn't know there was one here
when we were shopping for a video
supplies oh I bought all those as seen
on TV things that was like two years ago
are you oh you want a headlamp don't you
year old well it works the only problem
with my headlamp is it takes triple-a
batteries you can't just charge it with
a USB oh that's an especially when I'm
on out on the road you need to charge
and bring batteries come on yes no but
like not even for like going out and
shooting at night or whatever it's
primarily does does really trying to
take apart my PC and like leave it alone
it's fine stop trying to take a perfect
easy dog miss wheet you guys sit with
you but no it's finally than it is no
absolutely not no no no doesn't need to
get rebuilt no no I was saying it look
at this like beautiful you guys can't
see obviously let me just describe it to
you it's like a beautiful succulent
garden like I never get tired when you
live in California and you see plants
like that that don't exist
hey somebody's coming I love I love like
desert they're so beautiful
Oh ptooey only maybe on that note guys
this episode is brought to you by ok
miss me what is that
oh well it's much better than what
you're probably trailer feeding your dog
which is kibble and they don't enjoy it
the farmers dog packs healthy delicious
ingredients into your dog's food guys
are not getting out relax I'm just
reading a sponsor's ok she's so cute
being excited I need guys it is a
service that delivers balance freshly
made pet food with simple recipes and
Whole Foods she just bided so you're
doing because she's helped me like all
the time basically what you do is you go
on the farmers are calm Angeline and you
fill out little profiles about your dog
what they like to eat how often they eat
what they weigh what their activities
like whatever and their favorite foods
if they formulate a meal plan to where
they have these like pouches these pre
packaged pouches and you freeze them and
then you feed a media dog at the you
know these the corresponding schedule
depending on you guys weight and
whatever and it's so easy it takes us
two seconds to feed the dogs
yeah old feeding center was annoying
because we would have to break up his
patties and no farmer's daughter comes
in a tube you just you grab a little
important just it's a pouch it is great
guys so if you're curious about trying
new food for your dog look no further
than the farmers dog you will not be
disappointed and more importantly no nor
will your your furry friend
I'm talking she's so cute let her live
he said go to the farmers are calm /
Jenny Julien best ehe if they are M ers
do G slash annejulien and you enjoy 50%
of your two week trial of Amazon you
won't be disappointed
also guys when you are thinking about
building website look no further than
Squarespace Squarespace is website
building made easy okay you go to
Squarespace comm there's all these
different templates that you can use
there's customer service at any hour of
the night or day you want to build an
online shop a blog whatever it is for
your business for your hobby check it
out with Squarespace its website
building me completely easy we reach the
30 minute recording limit sponsor
squarespace.com Sasha and Julian ten
percent off your first purchase of a
website or domain Thank You Squarespace
you guys is actually super super easy
and I've been enjoying looking at the
websites that you guys make with
Squarespace when you tweet them at us
yeah you feel like nasty space there's
something on this week's episode of
jelly and Squarespace website highlight
we are highlighting a website called
serum it's nasty place uncle for a ride
they were already on a ride it was a
trick question
I can get a year at building up what his
nerves nerves wait are we going yeah
we're gonna strap bleach back in Beach
back so we try strapping them all back
in yeah alright why don't we do that and
then cut cut okay back back back we are
back
all we did was trap the dogs and you
know what I'm kind of confused
completely Pat there's not a parking
space here I'm used to I'm used to going
around on Sunday nights is just having
it be like pretty empty not like
literally Men's Wearhouse is packed
people really be out here buying suits
on a Sunday night
crummy sit
Wendy's these French fries are good some
of the Bauman's french fries I've seen a
couple people Christmas trees on their
roofs
did you ever have real truce growing up
because I did we always had real cherry
no actually I think a couple years I did
but I was never I was never like I don't
remember like making a day of it where
you go out we always had real trees they
always smelled so good and the pine
needles would start to fall off and get
all over the rug and they rot away no no
no no that's like when you get a real
tree it like forces you to take down
your Christmas tree at a reasonable time
Jan I remember my mom would always have
a real tree and always smells so good
and it was so fun you like bring it home
and let it open up for a little bit cuz
it's really cold and like stiff and up
there and my dad would have real trees I
think until we had a cat who loved to
just climb up it like he was such a
little [ __ ] and he would climb up the
tree and knock the entire thing over so
he started getting fake trees yeah like
it was it well it would be like the
middle of the night and you would hear
like it's a loudest crash ever
cuz the cat had climbed to the top of
the Christmas tree was up there just
like jingling [ __ ] around and knocking
the whole thing over
that cat was like he was just bless his
little heart he was an [ __ ] he was it
was it like truly an [ __ ] and my
stepmom like loved him more than
anything because she was like one of the
only people that he actually liked yeah
should we like put water out for like
you know how cats are weird and they're
like yeah they don't want to drink out
of their water dish they want you to get
them fresh water right now and just put
it in front of me she would like do nice
stuff for him like that and like not
touch him you know he's like Kermit but
like a mean cat really weird in
particular and like just just a weirdo
in a jerk like when I was little or my
dad's house got broken into on Christmas
Eve through my bedroom window and you
know so we're all like super we weren't
there we were at my aunt's house we got
home later that evening and the whole
house was like trashed it was terrible
and the cops were there and you know
we're like scared and like a little
shaken up like dad's obviously super
shaken up and we had been like crying a
little bit I think it was maybe like
8:00 and the cops came and the cops are
being super nice and like really nice
sauce cuz it's you know super messed up
your house got broken into on Christmas
Eve little kids and good cop dad had
this glove right because the only thing
that that cat liked to do was just like
attack things really hard play his game
called the glove with the cat and my dad
had this like like really badass like it
looked like a glove that you like catch
Falcons with yeah would put we would put
the glove on and then just let the cat
bite the [ __ ] up
material that those guys who get like
chased by dogs for to goose we had gone
through a couple of Love's you know so
we play the glove this cat it was Betty
and so the cops were there and you know
they're like they're cheering us up
they're trying to make us feel better
and out of nowhere the cat comes in like
it attacks one of their legs and you
know he's like I got [ __ ] like cat doing
and I'm like oh you want to play a glove
with them and the cops like okay like
here put this glove on in the car yeah
he just starts playing going here when
the cops hand he was like lots of it's a
great game you got there yeah all right
Merry Christmas thank you for coming by
it was fine you know like I obviously I
was too little to know what they took I
think that they took someone like my dad
had collectibles you know like he
collects stamps and like stuff like that
I think he said that they took like a
$2.00 bill or something cool but that
you know there wasn't really a lot in
the house that got stolen yeah he was I
thought it was more of just like the
shocker like yeah well my brother's room
was like trashed the whole thing was
just turned upside down like I don't
know what he was looking for if it was
like cash or electronics or I don't know
we didn't like I don't know exactly what
he took her didn't take but I remember
it wasn't like you know he came in and
stole our Christmas presents and like
stuff like that it was not too bad but
it's it's super invasive when someone
breaks in here
yeah I forgot about the glove like that
that was the cat that we would go over
there and it was like you know the
videos of kids just like walking by and
it catches attacks then like that was us
but there's like nothing you can really
do to stop a cat from like being an
[ __ ] you know just have scratches all
over our face and my mom was like what
is going on over there like oh the cat
he likes us he was a good play
it's Justin cries she just wants your
hand what's funny was totally unrelated
but it's sort of childhood I was
recently at my mom's house for
Thanksgiving and I totally forgot that
growing up for like years we had a
batting cage in the backyard dad really
turn aren't I it looks nothing like it
used to like my mom made it so nice but
it used to look like kind of a dump like
it was pretty much we have this little
grassy backyard and we put this like
batting cage up your mom's Korean house
yeah yeah so it's like if you go down
the back deck it's just it would've just
you would be touch the batting cage and
it was like net there wasn't like a hard
cage boy we like met in there had these
like little archways with like these
styrofoam was very janky but I
remembered that we had a batting cage
like multiple years and we would just
like hit the [ __ ] out of that cage to
the point where we would create holes
and then just the balls would go flying
through into the other neighbors all my
heart like broke glass and it was just
there and then the grass turned you know
like half the grass half mud pit
that's anyway that was that was my
childhood just it was between that and
playing basketball
dunk contest on trampoline don't contest
on the trampoline what the hell yeah we
would have done contests but those
weren't as intense that's like the 2v2
where was the basketball so it was on
the ground with the water base right
yeah it goes up to like 10 or 12 feet
and the trampoline sits like 3 and a
half 4 feet off the ground so we're just
dunking like crazy it's not even that
high for us but you get so high on that
trampoline that one person would go up
for you know to lay it up or dunk it and
the other person would jump just as high
and they'd be like their feet are at the
rim and you're just it's like what was
the craziest thing ever that sounds like
you guys are all really lucky that no
one that's what I'm saying like I'm
surprised it severed their leg
also I'm lucky I feel lucky that the
internet didn't exist cuz we would be
doing some really dumb [ __ ] to post if
we were yes I'm super glad the internet
right I just think it's such like it's
really tough I think about all the times
like in middle school and everything's
like such a big deal and like you know
knowing that maybe you didn't get
invited to somebody's party or something
or like the boy that you like it's like
hanging out with some other girl like at
least it wasn't in my face you know
getting out to see pictures of it or
like videos of it like it would that
kind of stuff is like so I'm so glad I
didn't have to I was too sensitive when
I was that age for that in general know
middle school I was way too sensitive
for everything you know know for sure I
will slowly towards the night like high
school years I did I do have like
Facebook everybody's now seen my super
deep didn't think I'd said it dear I
didn't think I cried but I shed a tear
but yeah you're right like middle school
it would have been rough and like every
middle schooler now is an iPhone pretty
much but yeah for me it wouldn't be as
much about like this social aspect but
it would feel like
I don't know like you're you wouldn't
have like a normal experience in school
because you'd be so like focus on
whatever dumb [ __ ]
is going on the Internet yeah I just
feel like it's so counterproductive for
a young person to be over consuming I
say that completely aware that I'm being
hypocritical because I consider the
Internet all day every day but
yeah I don't it's definitely not like a
bad thing obviously but I was just
really sensitive I was too sensitive and
I'm glad it didn't have that extra level
of things to cry about when I was like
13 you know I feel like we're we're wary
of different things I literally went
through college where like if not
everyone had a laptop or a smartphone or
even a phone at all you know like I had
a desktop computer all of college in
graduate school like I didn't have a
laptop and even if you did have like
that first generation iPhone that came
out like right at the end of when I was
in college it's like you you could get
on the internet but like if there wasn't
all the great apps and [ __ ] you know a
lot of social medias not it was Facebook
you know and like your internet was
hella slow and like what are you gonna
do go to a webpage like in class like
definitely not the same you know but I
went through all of college without
anything really like that was because I
was never had a blackberry yes so then
after that I was like okay I tried to
DIY this didn't work myself so I and
that was right around the time when I
was like a sophomore I think and I had
started to eat gluten-free because I had
been diagnosed with celiac and at the
time like you know I couldn't really
find things to eat out like I you know
it was really hard to like know where to
go
so my sales pitch to my mom was I need
you to buy me a blackberry because I'll
be able to use the internet when I'm out
in the world to do research on if I
could oh come on
and I'll do yeah I'd be sold opposed the
part I was like oh yeah sure and but it
wasn't like a scam I wasn't Joanne the
scamming her you kind of Joanne the
scammers damned her you did you did I
did maybe like two or three times in the
entire year you did maybe like two or
three times the entire maybe two years
that I had the blackberry used it for
that one purpose maybe like twice but I
did use it like that my all excuse like
all the way through high schools like if
I didn't call my mom it's cuz I didn't
have a quarter I was like sorry about me
I didn't have a quarter I think you're
talking about like sign for some girl
winning it hello like y'all Subaru oh
she
releasing of carbines yeah would be like
oh I'm so sorry to have a quarter to use
the payphone I know well you're talking
about Seinfeld like so many of the
problems in our eyes yeah so many of the
this situational things that they all go
through is like you know when you didn't
have a cell phone early you had to call
someone's landline and leave a message
but like you know when you tell someone
that you're gonna meet them X Y & Z
place that x y&z time like you're either
there you're not you know and then II
it's things that like don't happen
anymore wait what's that
t9 word was it was like the smart
texting system where you would if you're
typing on a numpad you could it would
like pretty much forget exactly I think
like sort of suggested quick quick words
that you just hit every key one's t9
word was dope that was like a [ __ ]
revolution
t9 word t9 wordy what was the invention
I came up with yesterday it was really
good
when vitamin ketchup oh my god
vitamin catch oh okay this whole
conversation started because we were
talking about how we love and our friend
Meg loves french fries and we love
french fries obviously because french
fries the like sometimes when we travel
that's all we can eat so we have this
weird really intimate relationship with
french fries where sometimes that's all
be for a weekend and we were talking
about how like it's hard to get your
nutrients when all you eat is french
fries so introducing
all your vitamins are in the ketchup so
you can just stop your face with fries
and get all your daily vitamins in
nature
it's so nasty it would taste exactly the
same depending on how good my scientists
are Julianne and it would be it would be
a staple in every restaurant soon enough
baby
vegans are nasty though like vegans with
vegans would buy that and eat that and
be like it tastes good I feel like
there's so much vegan food that like
will eat because you can eat it cuz you
know what I mean
and you're deeply appreciative that you
have an option but like it doesn't taste
that good but you also be like
vegans Nestle vegans would eat that and
be like I appreciate this so you have at
least a little bit of a market of people
that would be like YUM here's the thing
about ketchup and tomatoes by nature
have a very strong flavor they're sort
of like cranberry juice right he makes
cranberry juice with vodka you can
barely taste the vodka because it's got
a really strong potent flavor so ketchup
how's that going for it because you
could hide the taste of the vitamins
very well underneath a thick tomato e
ketchup flavor so you won't even know
that you're getting your vitamins you
just feel great all the time as you stop
for a food restaurant for the next
Julian that's you Nancy okay let's get
some really yeah what time do they close
I have a cut or slash a burn on my mouth
gee I wonder how you got that
think about what it's so gross julian
knowle vitamin ketchup okay well if it
doesn't turn into an invention can I at
least use a pen yes
I know I can only imagine who's up guys
we're vitamin ketchup this song is
called YUM
welcome back my intention channel this
week we're making vitamin cancer
what else can you invent no I invent us
another product for your invention
channel w a TI
[Laughter]
it's like Soulja Boy's knock off
electronics I don't know
hey Bobby make us another invention for
your invention channel what else you got
in the pipes tire soap okay it's
something you use to clean your car
tires but other than it's different than
traditional so hmm doesn't slippery when
you use it uh-huh right
yeah gets grippy so you wash your tires
and not only are you cleaning your tires
but it adds grip Wow could you add too
much grip and then your car is stuck oh
okay interesting is this a proprietary
blend of soap did they even bent it yeah
yeah what's it made out of you have a
team yeah what's it made out of all
right
I don't think iodine gets crappy oh all
right okay
I don't think iodine has the properties
of soap or grip speed-limit watch okay
so watch that you wear and everywhere
you go it has the speed limit dialed in
to your specific location I like it so
you have one watch that tells you the
time or things like that and one that's
just purely the speed limit probably bad
okay you go on the bus stop and you
okay I like it how do you okay these are
glasses okay I like it useful parking
coins yeah these are counterfeit
okay so you're making counterfeit money
is what you're saying
how can you market that fifty nine
hundred real dollars or counterfeit
dollars stare radars yeah you put them
on the tip of your shoe so there's a
shoe can detect when they're stairs and
running you oh okay
and then if there is stairs in front of
you it emits high frequency very very
loud noise mm-hmm to where only dogs can
hear you can't hear mhm so in this
situation where you can't see the stairs
in front of you you're walking your dog
and you're wearing these shoes it will
signal such a loud furiously barking and
at that point you know those stairs
somewheres Wow amazing and they only are
the size of one another shoe looks like
you're wearing two shoes I want this is
cutting-edge technology Jillian
license plate marker it's a marker that
you can draw any license plate to change
the numbers and letters and he can be
your time that's so illegal Wow your own
camera
it's an orange parking cone but there's
a camera on so if you are if you want to
spy on something just pretend there's
construction somewhere in put a cone
whoa
it needs to plug so it needs to be
inside you can see the plug does it shut
off after about 28 minutes 15 hello
also it doesn't take any current SD card
that exists on the market mm-hmm it only
takes a high-end $3,000 SSD that you
need to buy proprietarily from red
cameras oh my god and it still films in
240p Wow helpful
I'm excited for your YouTube channel of
only invention what happened
finally just a couple hundred thousand
dollars sitting around to make these
happen we would be we would be swimming
in real inventions and I would be from
all angles it would be swimming in real
inventions like so much I could have a
lawyer on retainer and it wouldn't even
help
why did you learn quit anyway this is
fun I love you know I'm going for rides
right so do you guys just a little and
cute back in the studio we're gonna be
back in that studio life yeah yeah yeah
yeah do do life okay I never say that
selfie with one year bone on never ever
say that again
stop it
thank you for screaming the whole time
[Music]
[Music]